is the s23 ultra a better phone than the
iPhone 14 pro Max well from the note
borrow design and the powerful speakers
to the USBC port and the 100x moon
faking camera yes but it's definitely a
bit complicated
now before you get triggered in Rage
comment because I said the words Moon
faking camera stop because I definitely
prefer what Samsung is doing compared to
the iPhone's potato cam photo but that's
not the end of the story in this video
I'm gonna get real honest and admit that
yes I have a personal bias towards
iPhones since I've been an iPhone user
for almost a decade and I can't let go
of how well it works with my MacBook Pro
but removing all iOS bias I have to
admit that the s23 ultra is a better
phone there I said it okay that was
painful but let's move on to the meat
the 14 pro Max basically looks the same
as it has since the iPhone 11 Pro save
for the dynamic Island that's honestly a
bit too big and the camera bump that's
getting endlessly bigger which I
actually like the more bump the merrier
right but honestly the design of the s23
ultra takes the cake with the camera
bump nicely planted onto a solid piece
of flush glass across the entire back
which is what I wanted Apple to do with
the upcoming iPhone 15 Pro no really
these are the renders I imagined and
asked shilesh to create camera bumps on
a flat piece of flush glass but no the
official case cats have leaked and we're
getting the same camera book design once
again so yes the s23 ultra wins in terms
of the design and it actually really
like this new matte red finish and I'm
really glad that they discontinued the
note series and simply gave that design
language over to the s23 ultra and the
real cherry on top is the fact that the
S Pen is once again integrated into the
design which is actually really handy
for filling out PDFs so with that said
it's basically now the best traditional
Android phone design out there now
Apple's method of removing the Notch and
replacing it with the dynamic Island was
a genius move because it keeps the face
ID sensors next to the camera while
mixing it up and making it look new not
to mention the various benefits of
displaying useful information like
timers navigation and even things like
sports scores but to be real Samsung's
little cutout is definitely the cleaner
option and it's much less intrusive
however face ID on the iPhone is a
million times better than Samsung's weak
fake recognition and I don't like
fingerprint sensors sorry Samsung
Fanboys but you can't convince me
otherwise anyway the displays on both of
these are great we've got high refresh
rate high contrast ratios great colors
High brightness they're equally great
yes the iPhone technically can get
brighter but it's only when you're
outside and using auto brightness which
I can't stand using so to me it doesn't
really matter they both get a win now
before I get into the cameras as as well
as the fake moonshot controversy I've
got to talk about the number one worst
thing about the iPhone and that is the
lightning Port but first I've gotta talk
about this the magic stem case from our
partner case Q which basically combines
the best and most Wanted aspects of a
case into one you've not only got a
great and durable design with strong
Maxi Magnus built in but the max safe
ring is literally on a hinge so you can
use it as a finger grip or a 40 to 120
degree stand for watching videos movies
anything else you want and the best part
is that it folds back completely flush
with the case so it doesn't interfere
with any of your max save charges or
accessories so check out this brand new
frosted color and all the discount info
using the link in the description below
now back to the lightning Port the 14
pro and 14 pro Max are plagued by it
because Apple has continued to increase
the camera quality with features like 48
megapixel Pro Raw photos that come with
massive file sizes as well as finally
adding 4K resolution to their cinematic
video mode which by the way I absolutely
love because it looks like real
professional video footage with blur in
the background so recently I filmed an
entire video's a-roll using my iPhone's
4K cinematic mode and knowing that
lightning is limited to incredibly slow
USB 2.0 transfer speeds I decided to try
and airdrop the 4 Gig file to my Mac at
the office well that was a mistake
because it took forever since it needed
to process the entire video into a
format that the Mac could recognize due
to using cinematic mode so it ended up
randomly failing the airdrop so then I
tried connecting my iPhone to my Mac
with the lightning cable and importing
the file but nope it said I had to
process the files first which was taking
forever and it just didn't work for some
reason then find finally I ended up
trying to airdrop it again and it worked
but it was of course very slow because
of that big file size now in contrast
the USBC port on the s23 ultra makes
this process so easy because even on a
Mac you simply connect it switch to file
transfer mode and Bam all your files
show up allowing you to Simply drag and
drop them onto your computer within
seconds thanks to the Blazing fast USB
speed that runs circles around the USB
2.0 limitation of lightning and that's
actually not the worst part did you know
that Apple's 2017 iPad Pro came with a
lightning Port that was dramatically
faster than the one in this new 14 pro
Max yes Apple screwed us over with the
same slow lightning Port as before even
though lightning is capable of faster
speeds like on the iPad anyway I'll stop
my rent there and say that I'm very glad
the upcoming iPhone 15 lineup is getting
USBC across the the board and the iPhone
14 will forever be known as the last
iPhone with lightning farewell we won't
miss you now as far as the performance
of the chips yes the iPhone's a16 chip
is technically faster with the s23 ultra
pretty much matching up in terms of GPU
performance but they're both so fast
that it doesn't even matter they're neck
and neck in speed tests online and in
terms of gaming performance Dame Tech
tested them out and there's basically no
discernible difference between them
other than heat and finally let's finish
off with the cameras Samsung's new 200
megapixel sensor is great but it's
actually a toss-up with the iPhone 14
Pro's 48 megapixel camera in terms of
quality probably because it's a new
sensor and we've got to wait for some
more software updates now other than
that the regular 12 megapixel main
camera photos are great on both of them
the ultrawide photos are very similar as
as well and even the Selfies are
comparable they're just both great
cameras now where the Samsung actually
takes the win is of course the 10x
Optical telephoto camera where it
clearly and easily beats the iPhone's 3x
lens and there's just no competition
that right there is the biggest downfall
of the 14 pro Max and because of it the
s23 ultra does have a better camera
system overall now as far as the
moonshot controversy Mr who's the boss
proved that Samsung is intentionally
faking moonshot photos in a recent video
even showing that they're overlaying
sharp crater textures which you can see
right here he even created a fake moon
with a paper cutout and the s23 ultra
did its best to turn it into a nice
looking moonshot so for those of you who
are saying it's the same AI processing
that every other phone does that is
completely false however the truth is
that regardless of how Samsung is doing
it the s23 ultra pumps out incredible
looking moonshots that the 14 pro Max
couldn't even dream of taking so it's a
major benefit for the hardware itself so
with all of that said yes the s23 ultra
is a better phone than the 14 pro Max
but that doesn't mean I'm switching I
love the iOS software that I'm used to I
love the Mac safe feature I love the
ecosystem and I especially love the 4K
cinematic video mode that blows away the
competition now if you disagree with me
let me know down in the comment section
below but if you enjoyed it click that
Circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]